[Music] I'm just so confident and comfortable Selena Gomez and the weekend hit Hollywood's new hot spot [Music] Selena and the star boy singer went out for a romantic date night on Thursday an eye witness tells ET the coordinating couple was first spotted getting sushi before heading to Beauty & Essex in Hollywood the good for you singer looked rocker chic sporting an oversized gray denim jacket black mini dress and matching boots while her boyfriend kept things casual in all black with red Pumas sneakers super casual Selena seemed to want to keep a low profile keeping her head down as the couple left arm in arm [Music] you